hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in virtue ethics as a resource for
business robert audi is going to make
some very useful distinctions for us
about how we can evaluate a person's
character in terms of virtues and also
by extension in terms
of vices and we might say well why is it
important that we care about people's
character at all isn't it really more
about the results or whether they fit
the role or whether they just did the
right thing they followed the rules and
procedures and audi points out that we
really can't get away
from concerns of character i mean we can
certainly set them aside with usually
bad consequences in the end when we hire
the wrong people and so he tells us that
any ethical theory in general should
help us to identify
morally good people so whether we're
utilitarians whether we're deontologists
whether we're virtue ethicists whether
we're employing you know an ethics of
care or something like that we do need
to be able to specify who counts as a
good person and why well there's all
these important domains hiring you want
to hire people who are actually going to
be good in general because they're going
to be good for your organization right
hiring people who have problematic
character traits
that's really playing with fire isn't it
you might say well we need these
go-getters who are totally selfish don't
be surprised then when they're stealing
from the company you know or abusing
things in other ways evaluating people
this is very important we have a
continual review process in many
companies and you're going to have to do
that eventually on the basis of
character and character traits promoting
people do you want to promote people
just because they followed the rules or
stuck themselves in a desk for a given
amount of time and now have seniority or
do you want to promote people partly on
the basis
of not just performance in terms of like
meeting you know benchmarks or deadlines
or quotas but also in terms of being
good people
if you don't you're gonna run into
problems sooner or later when we
discipline people when we say well
you've done something wrong what is the
sanction going to be are we going to
fire you right away are we going to not
only fire you but but maybe sue you as
well are we going to coach you are we
going to try to work with you to improve
on these these sorts of things that is
really going to depend quite a lot on a
person's character if you want to do it
well so we can't avoid
what audi here is calling virtue
concepts right he says
inside an organization
dealing with shareholders regulatory
agencies says doing this is for
practical purposes impossible without
relying on virtue concepts what are some
virtue concepts that he brings up here
honesty
honesty is a virtue concept it's not
just a checklist it's not an on off
switch it is a virtue concept uh
fairness loyalty and he says if we
cannot identify and describe morally
good persons in fairly simple terms you
can't do moral education and if you
can't do moral education you can't
really do coaching because coaching is
not identical with moral education but
that's part of it that's an important
part of it as people outside of ethics
proper but within those industries have
have recognized so
he goes on and he says in order to
understand moral virtue adequately
one thing that could be helpful for us
to make a distinction is about is
omnibus traits and virtues of character
so when we talk about
omnibus traits we mean things that are
covering everything and we evaluate
people in terms of them they could be
ethical or moral or they could be
non-ethical non-moral right so what
would be an example audi doesn't give
you any
but we could talk about somebody in
terms of aesthetics right
moral traits are going to be or you know
moral yeah moral omnibus descriptions
are going to be things
like
goodness
rectitude badness turpitude we don't
usually use rectitude interptitude all
that often they're sort of sim you know
you might say stricter sounding ways of
talking about goodness and badness
turpitude can be called evil if you like
or wickedness right
so you know the the people who set up
the ponzi schemes and defrauded
investors that's turpitude that's
wickedness right and we can also go on
to talk about particular virtues of
character so he says that
a person of rectitude is morally good
but it doesn't specify any particular
moral trait by contrast
justice fairness only honesty loyalty
and benevolence are specifically moral
traits and there's a correlative
relation between these the omnibus
traits allow us to describe a person
as a whole you know includes everything
omnibus that's what omnibus means and
then virtues of character allow us to
say this person is good or bad
in this way
they're good or bad by being
fair or unfair they're good or bad by
being diligent or lazy they're good or
bad by and we can go on and on and
specify additional ones so that's a very
helpful distinction he thinks and then
another even more important distinction
is and this goes right to the heart of
can we actually evaluate people
on the basis of virtue ethics not just
you know in in the large sense of their
character but also
when it comes down to individual actions
can we say well that was a good action
but it wasn't an actual virtuous action
even though it was in accordance with
virtue and the answer is yes
aristotle made a fundamental distinction
that was followed throughout virtue
ethics between people who do the right
thing in a particular case
by behaving in a way that a virtuous
person would
but aren't actually virtuous as a matter
of fact even a vicious person
could sometimes in some cases do things
that resemble the actions of a virtuous
person but they would be doing it for a
completely different reason
in order for a person
to be genuinely virtuous
they have to
have that virtue established as a habit
or a disposition within them as audi
remarks people having virtue will
naturally act virtuously though they're
doing so is by no means automatic and
this is what aristotle says you know the
virtuous person will reliably or
characteristically behave in the way
that a virtuous person does and they
will also desire to do so they want to
be virtuous they don't like when other
people aren't being virtuous when
they're being vicious
and so that is sort of the pinnacle
acting
from virtue you actually are a loyal
employee you have developed loyalty
within you it is part of who you are
it's become second nature to use
aristotle's phrase so you have the
established disposition you have the
right reasons or motivation for acting
and then you do the right action
it's also possible to be acting in
accordance with virtue and not be
virtuous you don't have the disposition
at all and you do the action for some
different motivation
or reason he talks about you know the
person who is establishing a a ponzi
scheme for for example that's not a good
thing right but um
you could you could you know do some
things in the course of that that are
good things
right
uh you know madoff was was taking from
some investors to pay off other
investors he said well
he was at least acting justly in that
respect but he certainly wasn't acting
in accordance with justice right there's
all sorts of ways in which people will
do something that is characteristic of a
virtue and virtuous people and then tell
themselves that they're good people
they're not
simply behaving bravely in one
circumstance because you're desperate
doesn't make you a brave person
you can tell because they're not going
to behave that way reliably
in other circumstances but then we have
a really interesting middle ground that
audi is bringing up
he says that
a person can act for the right sort of
reason
and so virtuously in a full-blooded
sense and not merely in conformity with
virtue
without having a virtue appropriate to
acting for that reason this can occur
during moral education in which one can
do things for good reasons along the way
to developing a virtue but before
succeeding moral education could be
everything from taking kids and trying
to teach them how to you know be decent
human beings and have it be part of
their character to coaching sessions
that you're going through where somebody
who actually has the virtue in question
is trying to help you learn how to
develop that virtue to doing self-help
on your own and engaging in disciplines
to gradually become a more and more
virtuous person you're doing so without
having the disposition at this point
but you do have the right reasons and
that leads to the right action so
there's a third possibility which is you
might say acting from virtue no longer
all caps but sort of in lower case
which is going to be dependent on other
people acting from
virtue and these are different
levels of goodness it's good to act in
accordance with virtue even if you're
doing it for the wrong reasons because
it's still a good act
right it's just not as good as it could
be
it's even better to be acting from
virtue but in some way where you don't
yet have the disposition
best of all is to be acting from virtue
because you actually have the
disposition and you are a just person
you are an honest person you are a
diligent person you are a loyal person
right so we can make these moral
distinctions these are all good
but some are better than others
so when to go back to this when we're
identifying good people who do we really
want to have we want to have people who
are acting from
virtue can we evaluate that in one
single interview probably not we have to
look at the way in which that person
behaves over time and we have to check
whether there's a kind of reliability or
consistency in their actions and we also
probably want to ask them why are you
doing the things that you're doing if
they say well i'm just doing it to make
a ton of money or to get people to like
me at best they're acting in accordance
with virtue so this is a very important
set of distinctions that can be quite
useful in applying virtue ethics in
business contexts
you